-Marlon Wayans!
-Thank you.
-Looking good, bud.
-As always, looking good.
-I'm fangirling right now.
I just got a peek
of Willem Dafoe.
I didn't get to meet him,
but I got to see him.
-Yeah, that's all
you really need to do.
-He has, like, one of
the most distinct faces.
-It's unbelievable.
-Although, with the mustache,
he looks like
Professor Hinkle from
"Frosty the Snowman."
[ Laughter ]
But he just always, like --
I knew he was Green Goblin
even with the mask on.
He has a very distinct face.
-Yeah, you just knew it was him.
-Like, even if he had played
Spider-Man with the mask,
he'd still be like...
-Yeah. You know.
You look great, bud.
-Thank you, man.
-Is this true? You turned 50?
-Yeah, you know that Black
don't crack unless you smoke it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you talking about?
-Let's be clear, Jimmy.
I turned Black 50.
[ Laughter ]
-What is Black 50?
-Oh, it's different
than white 50.
It's, uh --
[ Laughter ]
Black 50 is like --
We, like, 25 in the face
and, like, 82 in the prostate.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
White 50 look like it hurt.
Oh, my God. Ohh!
I see my white friend's 50,
I just hug them like,
"You ain't gonna make it to 51."
[ Laughter ]
-You got to celebrate it,
though, with your son.
-I just celebrated his 21st,
which was awesome.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, so, I flew in to Miami,
and we was gonna party all day.
And, you know,
I was down for it.
So I flew in, and we went
to Club 11 for breakfast,
which is a strip club, so...
That's how you want to spend 21.
And then that night
we went to Live,
and I get a text from my son
at like 2:00
and he's like, "We out."
I was there
until 7:00 in the morning.
I don't know
which one of us turned 50.
[ Laughter ]
-Kids don't want to
hang out late anymore.
-I don't know.
I'm like, "You ain't got no job.
Why are you going home?"
-That's wild, though.
That's crazy.
-Yes.
-You know what's interesting?
I just don't feel the need
to stay out that late anymore.
-That's 'cause
you're rich, Jimmy.
Uh...
Rich people just want to go to
sleep just to count their money.
"I don't need to go out.
We'll bring out in."
-[ Laughs ] Bring out in.
-Speaking of rich, listen.
I'm hosting -- I'm guest hosting
"The Daily Show,"
and I need a guest.
And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you talking about?
-And I figure you owe me
like 12, right?
Because I come on this show
and I give you a break.
You just be like --
[ Laughter ]
And I just sit here,
and I blap, blap, blap,
blap, blap, blap.
Because some guests,
it's like pulling teeth.
You know what I mean?
I don't know how to do this.
Your part -- I don't know
how to ask questions.
I'll be like this --
[ Laughter ]
[Snorts] "Yeah, give it up
for Marlon Wayans."
-What are you talking about?
-I need a guest.
So I need you to come
on "The Daily Show"
and let me interview you.
We don't know anything
about you.
I want to know why haven't you
let me come to the Hamptons.
I want to know...
how come you hang with the
brother from the "Hamilton,"
but I can't be in a pool
with you?
What's up with that?
[ Laughter ]
-How do you know I was in a pool
with the dude from "Hamilton"?
-I was going to --
I was personally going to reach
out and talk to you, right,
and invite you on to be
my guest, but then I realized
I ain't got your number,
so what I did...
was I used this opportunity
to be like,
"Yo, Jimmy, come on
'The Daily Show.'
Let me holla at you."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Marlon, I let "The Daily Show"
come to me.
-Ooh!
[ Audience ohhs ]
Ohh! Ohh!
Shots fired! Shots fired!
Ohh!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Shots fired!
Ooh!
That was good, Jimmy.
-That was not bad.
-That was good. See, that's why
I wanted you as my guest.
I knew you had jokes.
They don't know.
See, you had to come
from behind the desk.
Behind the desk,
it emasculates you.
You come over here, and you
start doing jokes at people.
[ Laughter ]
-Unbeliev--
What are they going to do?
"The Daily Show." What are they
going to do with Marlon Wayans?
-I don't know.
Nail me to the seat.
Because I don't know
how I'm-a sit down.
I'm not good at that.
-I can't see you behind a desk.
-I can't see me behind a desk.
-Get rid of that desk.
-My teachers couldn't see me
behind a desk
'cause I was cutting class.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk to you about --
There's two things.
Well, first, let's just
talk about "God Loves Me."
-Yes.
-Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-HBO Max.
-Yes.
-Why is it called
"God Loves Me"?
-Because I think
God loves all of us,
but he really loves me.
[ Laughter ]
Because I feel like
cataclysmic things happen
in the world that have nothing
to do with you, per se,
but then you think about it,
and it has everything
to do with you.
And one of those events
to me was SlapGate.
And when Chris Rock and Will
had that --
Yeah, when Will hit him,
life went like --
[Whooshing] for me.
Maybe Will hit him
that hard that I --
It changed my life,
and so I know Will,
Chris, and Jada,
and I was just like,
"Yo, somebody got to
talk about this story
from a loving,
funny perspective."
And so I called it
"God Loves Me"
because that slap had nothing
to do with the three of them,
had everything to do with me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm sorry. I'm so lost.
How did it have anything
to do with you?
-I don't know, but even -- Look.
It's like -- Questlove.
Why is he everywhere?
And it ain't got nothing
to do with him?
He was right there like,
"Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
I seen the brother
clutch his pearls.
He said, "What?!"
-[ Laughs ] Pearls.
-But he's everywhere.
One night,
it was me, Dave Chappelle,
Chris Rock, all of us on stage.
And I look on stage,
and I'm like,
"What the hell is Questlove
doing here?"
You look through history,
you are the Black Forrest Gump.
He's gonna be...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In classic pictures.
Him and Malcolm X by the window.
Like...
The Martin Luther King
assassination.
[ Laughter ]
-He's everywhere.
-Right.
-January 6th at Pelosi's desk.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my -- Dude.
-Ohh!
-Shots fired!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Dude. Good luck, "Daily Show."
You can't hold him down.
Marlon Wayans, everybody.
"Marlon Wayans: God Loves Me."
-Thank you.
-"God Loves Me" premieres
Thursday on HBO Max.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.